il ya eu sa version des faits qu'on a
entendu que ton avocat va nous rappeler
et toi aussi
alors donc toi parce que m ce que vous
voulez vous les interviews alors la
version des faits d' elle est simple
c'est à dire que nous maintenons que
jérôme a été atteint par un tir de l bd
alors que le ministère de l'intérieur
prétend que c'est un éclat de grenade
alors justement très vite laurent nunez
donc dit que l'utilisation du nbd face à
jérôme est loin d'être une certitude on
va regarder c'est passé juste ce que
nous savons c'est que policier a projeté
une grenade de désencerclement dans le
périmètre dans lequel se trouvait
monsieur monsieur rodriguez et le
policier qui a tiré qui a rédigé sera
paru et bien sûr bien sûr le policier
l'a rédigé puis on voit bien à l'image
un projectile qui semble être les
investigations judiciaires encore une
fois le confirmeront je suis très
prudent dans ce que je vous dis allez
voir des investigations sur le lanceur
de balles de défense pour moment je vous
parle je n'ai aucun élément qui me
permet de dire qu'il est à usage du
lanceur de balles de défense à cet
endroit là et qui aurait touché
monsieur rodrigue alors depuis l'affairé
a rebondi gironde puisqu'on a eu des
nouvelles de cette affaire est ce que tu
peux nous dire où ça en est aujourd'hui
et les derniers rebondissements tout le
monde aux téléspectateurs je dirais que
ça c'est du codes de langage
gouvernemental il savait depuis le
départ parce que l'on sait vraiment oui
pourquoi l'ancien gm pourquoi il ya eu
quand même 20 et bornier parce que moi
je suis numéro 20 d'accord donc pourquoi
lancer une enquête uniquement pour moi
bon je pense qu'il le savait dès le
début donc ils ont essayé d'assurer tout
de suite par rapport à avec la met la
police des polices pour faire la lumière
sur cette affaire
donc pour moi il savait depuis le départ
simplement donc on est sur du code de
langage on est sur du média on va pas
dire forcément oui on a visé jaune ça
serait un peu probable donc moi j'ai la
quasi certitude qui savait d'emblée
parce que faut savoir qu'à partir du
moment où il ya un tir de flash ball ou
un tir quelconque ça doit être relaté
dans l'eure c'est à dire la remontée
d'information doivent se faire dans leur
auprès de la préfecture ou fin du mois
auprès des autorités compétentes
donc il savait très bien qu'est ce que
vous attendez aujourd'hui vous qu'est ce
que vous attendez voilà du gouvernement
qu'est ce que vous attendez
voilà deux
de tout ce que vous avez fait ce que
vous dites aujourd'hui moi je veux
continuer je vais aller dans demain
demain est-ce que vous allez est-ce que
vous allez dans la rue demain moi ce que
j'attends déjà j'aurais ça m'aurait fait
plaisir d'avoir quelques mots d'excusé
aussi bien aux normes à personne que
l'ensemble des gens qui ont été
épargnées aujourd'hui où d'autres
blessés parce qu'il y en a certains qui
ont perdu des mains il y en a certains
qui ont perdu des pieds et c'est ça qui
est important même pas un mot d'excusé
même pas on se lève à l'assemblée
nationale quand on demande une minute de
silence pour les victimes
donc on voit un petit peu le respect que
peut avoir le gouvernement vis-à-vis de
son peuple et surtout quand il le blesse
donc ça ça me désole quelque peu
maintenant ce que j'attends c'est que
toute la lumière soit faite sur cette
histoire
pour montrer ma bonne foi et montrer
qu'il s'est vraiment passé quelque chose
ce jour là et savoir qu'est ce qui s'est
passé maintenant on commence les choses
commencent un peu un petit pas se
dessiner parce que le policier a fini
par se dénoncer
il a été de lui même dire qu'il m'avait
tiré enfin qu'il avait dix ans vous avez
tiré dessus soit disant qu'il ne m'a pas
obligé bas ils vont il a dit qu'il
n'avait pas dix et mais qu'il avait
effectivement tiré à savoir une balle
une victime au monde et c'est
mathématique
donc quand vous pensez qu'il vous a visé
en tout cas pas peut-être pas forcément
de ses biens après vous voilà pas vous
mais en tout cas j'ai été touché donc
j'ai été visés j'ai été touché trois
cadors mais voilà il n'a pas visé vous
vous dites n'a pas visé jérôme rodriguez
mais il y là il a en tout cas il a tiré
il a visé ce sont le voit sur la vidéo
quand on fait comme ça c'est pour viser
c'est pas non plus haut que leila ya une
enquête qui est en cours
jérôme moi juste parce que je vous ai eu
un petit peu toute la semaine est-ce que
vous en j'ai pas l'impression que vous
en vouliez à ce policier j'ai pas
l'impression que vous en vouliez
vraiment gouvernement j'ai l'impression
surtout vous êtes surtout dans le combat
vous dites j'ai envie de continuer et je
vois là je n'ai pas envie de m'apitoyer
sur mon sort c'est ce qu'on m'avait dit
pourquoi en vouloir aux jeux mais
perturbe le cerveau essayer de dons
vouloir à quelqu'un que je connais même
pas je vois pas l'intérêt de toute façon
tout le monde parle de violences
policières moi je parle de violence
gouvernementale parce que qui donne les
ordres de qui vient la responsabilité
d'armes et ces gens-là et de la demande
et de tirer simplement
ce sont des gens qui font partie d'une
corporation ils ont des chefs se doivent
de respecter les ordres c'est leur
boulot donc jusque là je peux le
concevoir
maintenant je les dis je les dis à la
police des polices au jour en sortant du
bureau qu'il précise à ce policier que
ni haine ni violence et que s'il était
prêt à s'excuser j'étais prêt à
l'écouter
voilà l'erreur est humaine celle
rencontrée vous avez envie de rencontrer
ce politique bat tant qu'à faire
on prend pas vous avez envie de quoi
devenir ont ils discuté avec lui d'un
oui pourquoi pourquoi exécuter des
ordres aux appareils parce que quelque
part on peut porter une carapace mais il
ya un homme là dessous donc un homme
avait forcément une conscience et tiré
sur son sur son concitoyen jld c'est
quand même un acte assez fort de pouvoir
tirer sur une personne qui vit dans le
même pays on fait partie du même peuple
on paye les mêmes impôts on vit dans la
même france je vois pas l'intérêt
aujourd'hui de tirer sur son peuple
je me fais la réflexion j'ai j'ai vu un
reporter de guerre reporter de guerre à
paris il ya deux mots qui vont pas
ensemble c'est ça tu vois ce que dira
guère paris dans des guerres giguère à
gilet jaune guerre dans la rue ouais moi
je suis né en 79
on nous a appris l'histoire de france on
nous a parlé de guerre de mais jamais
j'aurais cru vivre ça aujourd'hui à 40
ans qu'on le dise le mot guerre à paris
quoi il ya ainsi actes lorsqu'il va pas
là dessus plus qu'en région voilà c'est
vrai que toi tu réputé comme étant un
leader pacifique et fédérateur du
mouvement c'est ce que tout le monde dit
alors leader non parce que avant que
plus ça se passe j'étais plus acteurs
témoins de la situation acteur par
l'engagement et les différentes
organisations manifestations qu'on
mettait en place tout ce qui était
communication pouvoir relayer les infos
c'était plus mon rôle à moi de marché un
petit peu à l'ombre nombre pouvoir faire
en sorte que les gens puissent
manifester dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
qu'est ce qui m'a fait faire ça c'est
qu'à partir du moment où j'ai une petite
notoriété à l'échelle de la
manifestation parisienne
j'avais des retraités des gens à
mobilité réduite des familles qui
étaient désireuses de venir marcher à ce
moment là qu'est ce qu'on fait on prend
cette responsabilité ou pas donc je me
suis senti quelque part acquis d'une
cause de faire en sorte que plus ces
gens là puissent donner de la voix
d'accord retraités ont été aussi
maltraités par les programmes de macron
et il avait envie de donner la voix et
faire en sorte d'organiser ces
manifestations leur permettait de marché
discuter avec nous débattre et et crier
leur colère
alors et jérôme juste une dernière
question pourquoi es-tu descendus dans
la rue au tout début
toi tu étais plombier ce que tu m'as dit
la voilà tu es plombier d'ailleurs non
j'étais plombier en reconversion depuis
le mois de septembre c'est ça j'avais un
premier métier donc sans le vouloir j'ai
un petit peu écoutés macron quand il
nous dit traverser la rue pour trouver
du boulot d'aller voir ta soeur voilà
enfin ma soeur a pu m'aider à pouvoir
reconvertir dans un dans un nouveau
métier donc j'étais en plein en pleine
formation donc ça faisait quatre cinq
six mois que j'étais dans le boulot avec
un super m d'apprentis un ancien de
l'ancienne école en plus donc on apprend
énormément et aujourd'hui ben quand on
part sur un nouveau projet et puis que
six mois après ça s'arrête qu'est-ce
qu'on fait demain tu penses que tu
pourras peut reprendre ton métier les
différents passages chez le docteur ou
les différentes commissions d'invalidité
ou quelque chose le détermineront par la
suite d'accord donc ça risque d'être
très très compliqué bon j'ai trois mois
pour y réfléchir parce que pour
l'instant je suis son ami qui était de 3
mois
essayer de trouver une solution quant à
ma vie future du moins
professionnellement parlant quoi alors
giron on va parler bien sûr de la loi
anti casseurs est ce que c'est la
solution pour stopper les violences dans
les manifestations
alors on va donner d'abord la parole à
nos intervenants vous dit me mohamed
vous dit non non je pense que c'est la
preuve d'un pouvoir faible qui apporte
ses citoyens soucieux castaner a dit
qu'il fallait débattre et pas se battre
moi lorsque je vois les gilet jaune
je vois qu'ils cherchent à combattre
mais pacifiquement et ils ne sont pas là
pour se prendre des tirs de flashball et
on a l'exemple
malheureusement des gens de ce qui se
passe au quotidien on nous a dit écoutez
monsieur rodriguez je suis déçu je vous
le dis très sincèrement merci de ce que
vous faites vous et les gilet jaune
parce que vous avez apporté un vent de
fraîcheur dans la démocratie et dans la
vie politique et vous avez réussi quand
je dis vous c'est vous et les gilet
jaune a apporté des choses
extraordinaires
j'ai vu dire dans un reportage d'envoyé
spécial une famille avec une dame qui
pendant la semaine
mangent que de la soupe et le week end
bah finalement elle donne de la viande à
ses enfants et à la fin du reportage on
explique que grâce aux mouvements des
gilet jaune alors une prime d'activité
de 400 euros
essai de l'homme s'est mis à pleurer à
la fin et s'est mis à pleurer parce
qu'elle s'est dit je vais pouvoir
nourrir mes enfants je vais pas partir
en vacances à bora bora
mais j'ai peut-être pour regarder un
petit peu moins donc ce que vous
apportez extra est extraordinaire et si
on veut vraiment arrêter ces
débordements il faut que le gouvernement
écoute l'urgence sociale
qu'on arrête ces codes de langage
lorsqu'on l'a entendu monsieur castaner
dire juré qu'il n'avait pas eu de tirs
de l bd le jour de votre accident puis
dira finalement c'est une grenade de
désencerclement puis finalement
quelqu'un a tiré et malgré tout personne
ne reconnaît l'erreur et le problème est
là l'humilité
le fait de dire on nous sommes désolés
nous avons fait une bêtise et on voit
bien
vous n'avez pas de haine vous cherchez
justesse que justice soit faite en
revanche lorsqu'on a eu christophe le
boxeur la ja ubaye enquête tout cas
enquête il a directement été mis en
prison
donc je pense que vous êtes à la
recherche d'une justice d'une
condamnation peut-être mais surtout
cette loi je pense ne changera
strictement rien